quanti di voi conoscono iron man
come sapete è un uomo che indossa una
sorta di armatura che lo rende più forte
no per dire meglio indossa un
esoscheletro ecco che sono qua oggi per
parlarvi di esoscheletri cioè robot
indossabili quindi parlerò di
fantascienza oggi no non proprio ci sono
tanti centri di ricerca oggi che
studiano e progettano questo tipo di
tecnologia
tant'è che in un futuro non troppo
lontano potrebbe diventare qualcosa
veramente di quotidiano e quindi
potremmo qualche anno chissà aprire il
nostro armadio e trovare oltre la giacca
il nostro scheletro personale
ecco ma come fate un esoscheletro
abbiamo detto è un robot indossabile
indossabile perché
diciamo accoglie le nostre articolazioni
e quindi e ci consente di assecondare il
movimento un po come un vestito
robot perché fa fatica al posto nostro
ecco tra gli esperti di questa
tecnologia c'è il laboratorio di
robotica percettiva aperto
dell'università scuola superiore
sant'anna di pisa che ha un'esperienza
di oltre 20 anni nello studio di questa
tecnologia
recentemente valide e retina ed alla
ricerca ma portando alla costituzione di
una spin off cioè un'azienda che mette
sul mercato i risultati di idee nate
dalla ricerca e la nostra azienda si
chiama guerra ball robotics cioè
robotica indossabile e chi ne tecnica è
la divisione medica appunto ma a che
cosa serve un esoscheletro un
esoscheletro nel settore medico nello
scalo di cio serve nella riabilitazione
come molti di voi sapranno la
popolazione media mondiale sta
invecchiando quindi vuol dire purtroppo
che ci sono molte più persone che hanno
bisogno di aiuto di cure
ecco
quello che
accade per esempio se andiamo a vedere
l'ictus pensate che in un anno
15 milioni di persone sono colpite da
ictus
i due terzi di questi sopravvivono e
possono intraprendere un percorso di
riabilitazione per esempio la
fisioterapia che è un tipo di percorso
che consente di recuperare la mobilità
per esempio delle articolazioni e
muscoli
la capacità di deambulare cioè di
camminare
ecco
supponiamo quindi di voler fare la
riabilitazione dell'arto superiore con
il nostro ultimo scheletro da poco
sviluppato che abbiamo battezzato alex
alex può aiutare il paziente in modi
diversi per esempio il video della pista
può impostare il robot in modo da
guidare il paziente nei movimenti che
deve fare così come il fisio della pista
guiderebbe il paziente
il vantaggio qual è che se ad esempio
dobbiamo fare un esercizio per un po di
tempo qualche giorno
ecco che il fisioterapista imposta alex
una volta è la macchina dopo fa da sé il
vantaggio è che a parità di
fisioterapisti possiamo aiutare più
persone
attenzione però non fa tutto il robot
lo scopo finale è che la persona possa
recuperare le sue capacità motorie
quindi si dice che il robot alex coopera
con il paziente e questo livello di
cooperazione variabile in particolare di
cresce nel tempo quindi all'inizio il
robot ci metterà molto del suo il
paziente potrà metterci poco
man mano che si progredisce si va avanti
nel tempo il robot da un contributo una
cooperazione sempre più bassa nel
frattempo il paziente da un contributo
sempre maggiore fino a che riusciamo a
recuperare la capacità motoria
un altro aspetto interessante degli
esoscheletri che possono essere
integrati con tecnologie di realtà
virtuale cioè per esempio possiamo
indossare un caschetto e interagire con
un ambiente virtuale facendo dei
semplici per esempio semplici azioni dei
giochi stringere la mano a un avatar
fare dei semplici giochi cosiddetti
serious games giochi seri letteralmente
vuol dire che sono dei giochi che non
hanno solo uno scopo ludico e basta
l'intrattenimento ma tendono diciamo
invogliano la x anche lì sta facendo
stimano la persona che sta facendo a
fare quel determinato tipo di esercizio
di cui ha bisogno
infatti come potete immaginare
in tutto questo c'è una fortissima
componente psicologica
noi
lavoriamo da diversi anni collaboriamo
con l'azienda ospedaliera universitaria
pisana e conosciamo molte persone che
purtroppo si ritrovano da un giorno
all'altro a non potete utilizzare il
proprio braccio come facevano fino a
poco tempo prima
quello che accade a questi uomini e
queste donne che quasi dimenticano l'uso
di questo braccio
e questa una serie di influenza sulla
vita quotidiana
basta pensare doversi lavare vestirsi il
comportamento a tavola
hai una mano che però non puoi
utilizzare ecco la nostra vision quello
che vogliamo fare noi è dare una mano a
queste persone
ecco ma non siamo i soli a farlo nel
mondo ci sono
diversi abbiamo detto centri di ricerca
laboratori che sviluppano esoscheletri
pensate che esistono i suoi scheletri
per le gambe che sono in grado di far
camminare nuovamente le persone che sono
sulla sedia a rotelle
però come ho detto anche prima è una
tecnologia comunque parzialmente
immatura e che ancora in fase di
sviluppo per esempio uno degli aspetti
in cui vorrei parlarvi è il fatto che
molti degli esoscheletri che oggi
esistono montano per funzionare dei
motori elettrici che sono montati in
corrispondenza delle articolazioni cioè
sul gomito sulla spalla eccetera lo
svantaggio di questo è che questi
scheletri possono diventare un po
ingombranti e quindi non consentire a
chi li sta indossando di avere quella
capacità di movimento
tipica che avrebbe la persona in maniera
naturale parliamo rivestito però se
diventa qualcosa di eccessivamente
ingombrante allora diventa un pochino
più difficile fare determinati tipi di
movimento i movimenti ecco uno dei
nostri contributi in questo senso è il
fatto di montare a questi motori che
servono ad azionare il robot da un'altra
parte in uno zaino che viene indossato
dal paziente e questi motori sono
collegati con i piccoli cavi che
arrivano alle articolazioni gli uomini
tra spalle eccetera quindi permettono e
permettono il movimento il vantaggio è
che le parti mobili nessuno scheletro e
molto snello e molto leggero e quindi
ecco che possiamo effettivamente
effettuare tutta quella serie di
movimenti che normalmente saremo
abituati a fare con il nostro braccio e
che non potremmo fare con delle
soluzioni più ingombranti
ecco adesso vi faccio vedere un breve
video
questo ecco era per quanto riguarda come
detto la riabilitazione
però in realtà sono altri utilizzi altri
scopi per cui possono essere utili dei
suoi scheletri ad esempio quello
dell'assistenza per esempio supponiamo
che io debba sollevare un carico da 10
15 kg ecco se io lo faccio indossando un
esoscheletro possa sollevare questo
carico senza sentire sforzo perché ci
pensa l'esoscheletro
pensate quindi al vantaggio che ci può
essere per esempio per gli operai del
settore edilizio per esempio che questi
durante la loro vita lavorativa
sollevano e movimentano carichi di
grande entità lunghi tempi quello che
accade normalmente purtroppo è che dopo
anni
vengono diciamo in svolgono delle
malattie all'apparato muscolo
scheletrico questo genere di malattie
potrebbe essere evitato se la persona
indossate l'esoscheletro che quindi
farebbe lo sforzo
lui comunque garantendo di quella
ampiezza di movimento che gli è
necessaria per compiere quel determinato
tipo di operazione
ecco questo tipo di
idea attualmente ha un piccolo
svantaggio se vogliamo un limite che è
quello dell'autonomia energetica ovvero
questi scheletri possono funzionare per
un certo una certa quantità di tempo per
qualche ora in generale
dopodiché un po come i nostri telefonini
no vanno ricaricati ecco cerchiamo di
capire vediamo come abbiamo cercato di
affrontare questo questo problema
io prendo questo libro e lo voglio
sollevare portare in alto
faccio questa cosa qua niente di più
cosa ho fatto ho speso energia ho fatto
uno sforzo fisico ho dato energia al
libro importarlo in questa posizione
se lo riporto indietro
faccio niente meno che questo adesso se
voglio ricominciare da capo ecco che se
lo voglio quindi di portare in alto devo
di nuovo spendere energia a fare uno
sforzo fisico
e siamo arrivati qua
però se ci pensiamo noi
in realtà il libro nella fase di discesa
potrebbe fare da solo io sto frenando
quindi energia per andar giù
ecco allora ci siamo detti qual è l'idea
nella fase di discesa in cui ho questa
energia che butto via queste di buttarla
via la recupero la metto da parte in un
serbatoio serbatoio di energia a cosa mi
serve la prossima volta che voglio
sollevare il libero nello spendere
energia ma prendono energia dal
serbatoio in cui l'ho messa prima nella
fase di discesa
complicato
se ci pensate abbiamo un esempio sotto
gli occhi tutti i giorni
quanti di voi conoscono questa lampada
dita delle mani
moltissimi quasi tutti ce l'avete a casa
se l'avete in ufficio ecco se ci fate
caso questa lampada a delle molle
cosa sono il serbatoio di energia e con
gli stavo parlando prima quindi vediamo
di capire com'è come funziona io posso
prendere questa lampada al fisso la base
la posso spostare
in qualsiasi posizione io desideri e la
lampada mi accorgo che effettivamente
resta sempre in quella posizione si
chiama equilibrio indifferente vuol dire
che la lampada e le molle si scambiano
continuamente una certa quantità di
energia in particolare quindi se io
voglio andare in alto ecco che
le nuovole danno energia la lampada
quindi si accorciano viceversa quando io
voglio scendere portare giù la lampada
prendo per l'energia dylan magazzino
nelle molle e quindi si allungano
ecco ma
visto tutto questo ci siamo chiesti ma
ci può essere utile può darci una mano
nella nostra per i nostri su scheletri
per la nostra tecnologia possiamo
innovare ecco noi crediamo che innovare
sia farsi sempre domande non smettere
mai di farsi domande chiare si perche
delle cose ma tutte qualsiasi fare come
bambini che non richiedono ma perché ma
perché ma perché bisogna fare così non
bisogna accontentarsi di quelli che ti
dicono
sei sempre fatto così va bene lascia
stare così il punto no bisogna guardare
oltre pensare farsi sempre domande
sempre e noi ci siamo detti possiamo
fare qualcosa del genere per i nostri su
scheletri sì non è banale ci sono dei
brevetti d'accordo però si può fare ecco
ma che significa
tutto questo in parole povere che si
vedono all'esempio dell'operaio del
settore edilizio non solo se questo
sulla leva a suo carico da 15 kg lo fa
senza sforzo
ma lo fa e lo muove come crede senza che
io consuma energia elettrica dei motori
dell'esoscheletro e quindi capite dove
siamo partiti dal problema
dell'autonomia energetica
arriviamo a una tecnologia a un rivetto
che ci consente di avere un notevole
incremento dell'autonomia energetica di
questi dispositivi
ecco recentemente stiamo sviluppando e
portando a termine il progetto di un
esoscheletro completo cioè braccia e
gambe
el'assistenza quindi allevamento carichi
basato su questo principio suo principio
che appunto consente diciamo una elevata
autonomia energetica su questo grosso
serbatoio di energia perché in qualche
modo mettiamo delle molle con po come
sulla lampada nel nostro esoscheletro
che sarò che però sono regolabili sono
dei piccoli motori che consentono che
che solo quando vogliamo cambiare il
carico vanno utilizzati per regolare le
molle altrimenti non c'è consumo
energetico e quindi parlando di energia
e quindi con questa idea dell'energia
ecco è proprio grazie all'energia che il
nostro team ha nostra squadra ha messo
in questo progetto in quest'idea che
abbiamo avuto l'onore è a fine 2013 e di
vincere il premio gaetano marzotto
l'impresa del futuro che
consiste in una somma di 250.000 euro
per finanziare il progetto è un
contributo formativo per le persone
supporto nella gestionale dell'azienda
quindi
noi andiamo avanti diciamo continuiamo
il nostro lavoro con un'idea costante
che
la tecnologia può davvero aiutare a
migliorare le nostre vite
piace